that was gotham knights and now we
welcome oh look who it is neil druckmann
from naughty dog
co-president of naughty dog uh great to
have you with us neil it's been a uh an
eventful day on the internet for naughty
dog fans and uh i think we jinxed
ourselves we were joking about last
night like watch the assets will leak
and lo and behold that's what happened
well the good news is there's some stuff
that hasn't leaked that we have lots to
share with people about uh all things at
naughty dog but first of all it is a you
know it's a big month actually for last
of us fans because uh last of us one and
two both launched in june and it's
nearing its two-year anniversary for
last of us uh part two which is hard to
hard to believe
yeah it's crazy uh um you know nine
years for last of us one two years for
less was part two and we still hear from
fans they're still sending us letters
and art and these characters in this
journey and this world mean so much to
them
um
and it's it's just been kind of amazing
like last week's part two early this
year passed a pretty big milestone and
sold over 10 million units
and that kind of support that kind of
success we're so grateful to our fans it
has allowed us to grow as a studio and
now we can take on multiple projects
more than we've ever had at the same
time
multiple projects okay very interesting
so uh what can last us last of us fans
expect in the future from you thank you
for asking jeff uh so one of the things
we've mentioned a while back is what
started out as a multiplayer mode has
evolved due to the team's ambition they
really wanted to do something beyond
what we've ever done before at naughty
dog and we felt the way to do it justice
is to make it a standalone title and
over they've been working on it for the
past two years ambition has grown and
we're not quite ready to fully unveil it
but ready to lift the curtain a little
bit and just give you like an update of
where we're at
okay well uh what can you tell us about
this new standalone multiplayer game
yeah so uh we have a concept art that we
want to show um
uh but what i can tell you oh
is that this game is big okay um it's as
big as any of our single player games
that we've done and in some ways bigger
it's got a story um the way we're
telling that story is very unique to
this game um it's got a brand new cast
of characters it takes place at another
place another part of the united states
it's like a city might somewhat familiar
some people i'm sure our fans have
already figured it out um
uh and it's it's really cool and it's
being headed by venus agarwal um anthony
newman and uh joe padnaty all veterans
of uncharted and last of us and you're
gonna see a lot more of this game come
next year
next year so wait till next year to hear
more about that one okay well very
exciting that uh this has evolved and i
mean that concept art looks incredible i
can't wait to see naughty dog
storytelling fused with multiplayer live
game uh it's it's something special we
can't wait to show it either okay well
um that's not all we also have something
that i've been reading about on the
internet every day it feels like up in
calgary they're filming the last of us
show for hbo right
yeah so uh for the past year um you know
we've teamed up with craig mason of
chernobyl fame and hbo to adapt the last
of us into a tv uh tv show um they've
been filming and uh
it's pretty incredible the stuff i'm
getting back when we're looking at back
at naughty dog we can't help but feel
emotional because not only is it so good
and the quality is so high it's so
authentic to what we've made in the game
um and
uh i i just can't i couldn't be proud of
like again craig and that whole crew and
everybody that's up there uh and they're
actually their last day of filming is
tomorrow so the entire series last day
of filming they are filming us tomorrow
craig is up there right now kind of
wrapping it all up uh so it's it's
pretty close it's closer than you might
think and you actually got to direct one
of the episodes
yes uh i think that really speaks to the
kind of collaboration and trust that
exists between naughty dog and hbo they
invited me to direct one of the episodes
um i think we have an image from the
episode actually directed ooh
we could first look let's take
so you can see uh this is a certain
museum that players might know from the
game
and i really have to talk about pedro
pascal and bella ramsey and not only
directing them but seeing them do all
the other episodes they've thrown
themselves at these roles for a whole
year
watching the nuance that they bring to
these characters their relationship on
and off camera i couldn't help but think
about troy baker and ashley johnson it
felt so similar to the chemistry those
two actors had when we made the game
and it really feels like this is going
to be
something special and i will say this
will be the most authentic video game
adaptation yet well i mean that first
image that they put out it just i mean
it feels like the video game everything
that i've seen both public and other
stuff makes it feel sort of super
legitimate you said and that's awesome
to see uh julian ellie from from the
front side now for the first time um so
we'll see more of that next year that's
coming as well right serious uh you'll
hear about it very soon that's okay i'll
say right now all right well last of us
hbo very very exciting uh and i hear you
actually have a couple actors from the
show who are going to join us we happen
to have a couple actors here that are
part of the show we should bring them up
okay come on up
oh what's up guys hello
surprise troye's back again hello
good to see you uh i'm a little confused
though i thought maybe pedro bella but
troy ashley out here uh from the game
right so uh when craig and i started
working on the show almost one of our
very first meetings we said troy and
ashley have to be a part of it um and
we're such fans of like the talent and
the help like helping us create joel and
ellie um we felt like it was so
important that they become part of the
show and it wasn't
it has to be more than just like kind of
like a wink to the camera and like a
cameo these are real roles that we're
keeping on the wraps for now
uh but man i was i'm bummed that i
couldn't be there with you guys when you
filmed your stuff there's been so much
stuff so like so good on the internet
there's so much like talk about what's
being filmed and i think that's you guys
have kept a complete secret that you so
you were up there and you filmed your
roles by now obviously well keeping
secrets with this franchise is kind of
old hat like we've had for today
except for the date
uh it was it was one of the hardest
things for us to do is to let not let
people know that because we're so proud
of it and the work that we did we worked
hard the crew i have to say um when i
walked out on set
um
to be met with literally every person
that i met on that crew
is such a fan of this game and they all
knew what it was that they were working
on and committed to working on this
project because of their fan and their
love for the for the game uh was one of
the greatest it was like i was coming
home to friends
yeah i i the attention to detail
the crew was amazing bella and pedro are
man
i
they're so perfect and it it we've been
trying to sort of describe that feeling
of sort of seeing them in person
it's it's like
it's like the characters coming to life
but it it
it's so much more than that i feel like
i can't fully explain it but i am
so excited to be a part of it and just
i can't wait to see it i think it is
going to be
so good
it's it's i love the story i love
just being a part of it i'm so excited
about the series and the fact that you
guys are going to be in it and
undisclosed roles i'm so fascinated how
it's going to sort of
bob and weaving and you know are these
characters we know from the game that
they're playing new characters can you
tell us anything
yes
i can tell you so sneaky all right well
we're so excited maybe it's already on
twitter by now
hey all right well
let's talk about what was on twitter
earlier uh today lots of talk about uh
the idea or really what's happening is
it looks like you guys are remaking the
original game and this is like a
ground-up remake is that right that's
right uh we wanted to give people the
definitive version of the first game
that wasn't encumbered by any technology
i wanted to find a way to get even
closer to our original vision and we're
able to do it on the ps5 and pc and
instead of talk about it let's look at
it all right let's take a look at the
last of us part one
so why'd you leave boston
i've been on quite the adventure little
brother
i reckon it's got something to do with
that girl
he's got everything to do with that
little girl
you know
i've never been this close
it's the outside so is that everything
you hoped for
can't be any worse out there
can it
[Applause]
once upon a time
i had somebody that i cared about
and in this world that's good for one
thing
get you killed
i can take care of myself how many close
calls have we had
i get in trouble down there you make
every shot
count
i got this
hope you know how to use that thing
i've had some practice
truly one of my favorite games of the
past decade guys what's your reaction to
that yeah we haven't seen that yet yeah
you're watching it in real time yeah
uh
it's cause you did these before i mean
these performances you did a decade ago
yeah you didn't go back in i mean you
used the original performances yeah
actually we came up with a process where
you could take the original uh animation
that we did for the faces and kind of
like retarget it on these new rigs that
have a lot more fidelity and then the
animators went back and forth side by
sides here just how much it has changed
that you went and you redid the models
and rebuilt everything everything was
rebuilt from the ground up uh same art
director re-art directed the whole thing
from the ground up um but the the great
thing about these faces is that um
they're closer to their original
performance all the animators went and
studied those videos and got it closer
to what you did on set than we could
have achieved before
and that's just like one of the things
and we could talk about like this brand
new ai like all the combat is redone
just uh the fidelity of everything 60
frames per second all the stuff you're
getting on the ps5 again we wanted to
give knowing because of the show because
this they're all all new players for ps5
and pc we wanted them to have the
definitive version of the last of us
amazing well now you guys get to replay
i mean when's the last time you guys
played the game
i i actually played it again just to
refresh my memory before working on the
show
um
i was a just a glutton for punishment
and i went straight from playing uh
never playing straight into part two
um and so the last time i played
literally would have been two years ago
since we're celebrating the anniversary
of part two coming out so i mean it
looks like i'm definitely going to be up
for another playthrough
yeah i can't wait to go back because i
can't you guys do such an amazing job on
that original game and it's it's really
when you play it when you see it in
motion it's really night and day from
what it used to be imagine that you know
the think of the last of us two combat
but kind of that back in the last of us
once the whole like all the new
animation system the new ai system
everything we've learned on like
untreaded four last of us two we applied
to this again to give that definitive
version just to give a quick shout out
uh this project is headed up by matthew
gallant and shauna skye
and you'll hear a lot more about and see
a lot more about over the coming weeks
leading up to the release september 2nd
on ps5
all right well surely they're after on
pc we will look forward at night neil
you've talked a lot about
games directed by other people what are
you directing you still making games
still making games uh i haven't given up
my my day job
uh
it's a little early to talk about it
maybe if someone in places wants to leak
it then we can talk about it now uh
otherwise uh we'll save it you do have a
new project do have a new project but
we'll save it for another summer game
fest okay
okay well we'll see we'll try and save
it all right troy ashley neal thank you
so much for dropping by summer game fest
and i am so excited that the last of us
is returning as you said in september so
thanks guys appreciate it thanks jeff
awesome
all right well